podes o produtor nem palavras são coisas
muito
pra mim é interessante é o que nós
estamos compartilhando aqui palavras né
elas expressam idéias expressão sonho
inspiração tudo um cara que inventou
alfabeto na fantástica coisa e essa e
essa coisa que mas que essa paixão por
palavras não só é necessária a minha
profissão mas eu aprendi com meu pai e
meu pai é um homem um baiano um metro e
cinquenta e oito que teve uma vida bem
geladas do quatro anos mas aprendeu
muito na vida e aprender principalmente
aprender nos ajudou a todos os filhos a
terminar o ensino médio sempre foi uma
fonte de consulta para nós em
praticamente tudo num e um dia eu estava
com problemas com frações que eu vou
fazer lá o meu pai era um pai ou um
pouco sem graça mas situações ele porque
o problema não é que a edição este
número há dois iguais os denominadores
iguais eu tinha que repetir o delineador
somado o vereador e agora se tenha de
novo e diferente
esse é o problema a e que é o
denominador tomando muito baixo num a
resposta não é assim
o professor falou a ele odiava isso
assim não falei o que eu ouvi num pega o
dicionário é matemática
o funcionário que tenha denominador
então fui lá nós temos cinco volumes do
casal legions resolveram top surdo
peguei o segundo a ser o bendito verde
estava lá é o que denomina o que designa
o que dá nome
esse é o momento que ele faz pela função
do nome a função exata e mostrou que um
quarto foram 441 sexta um sexto dos 6 e
8 do nome para 38 autos não é e eu
fiquei muito feliz com isso mas assim
não estava resolvendo o meu problema né
se não vou explicar é o seguinte
lá ele abre o estojo lápis max quanto é
há também uma borracha mais uma borracha
do bicho é isso e agora não dá só uma
lacuna da são diferentes encontra o
mesmo nome pra eles de duas coisas e
isso tudo é coisa e ir e vim da infância
trazendo para o menor denominador comum
dois itens do meu esposo fantástico mas
ao menos seis ou mais infrações
aí ele isso não tal de algoritmo que
chamava de armar contra ele e eu
consegui descobrir que o mmc de aqueles
número é 24 e aí um quarto virou
magicamente ou seja 24 anos um cesto
virou 4 24 14 etapas virou todas 24
conseguir somar de outubro 22 24
aí ele falou assim é assim se você dá o
mesmo nome
você consegue somar frações se consegue
somar coisas a ele para ele diz o
seguinte a gente é a mesma coisa
então essa pérola de sabedoria é o que
construiu o projeto resgate ea primeira
o denominador comum que a gente
encontrou foi compaixão e nós
brasileiros nós somos cheio de compaixão
nós somos latinos somos emoção então
para terça feira eu perdi a voz eu
estava em uma reunião com a diretoria da
empresa e eu perdi a voz totalmente que
muito e eu tinha um evento importante na
terça feira à noite eu não conseguia
falar
às vezes eu conseguia sussurrar
interessante
a nossa secretaria começou a sussurrar
pra mim olha o que existam 'surra' não
sei por que as pessoas não favorece
começará a a partilhar o meu sofrimento
isso que se vê a compaixão paixão latim
significa sofrer com paixão é sofrer com
então com tv paixão de cristo não se
refere a um cross que jesus tinha mas o
sofrimento ea morte dele
então e agora mais curioso foi o
porteiro do teatro lan que eu precisava
de um blog te pedi pra ele e ele achou
que eu tinha pedido a audição também mas
ele totalmente se colocou no meu lugar e
compartilhou do meu sofrimento com
paixão a justiça no brasil
a pessoa que nasce pobre morre pódio ela
na porta no lugar de morar num lugar de
pessoas pobres na escola pobre sistema
de saúde é pobre a segurança nós sabemos
o que é é é isso
o norte sul leste oeste e pop pobre até
morrer a menos que algo aconteça isso
parece errado é errado
isso é uma civilização política deverá
sim mas é assim é sistêmico e muitas
pessoas indicam com isso e sim o
denominador comum você ver que diminui o
terceiro e solidariedade noturna tim em
sólido 1
estamos juntos no mesmo barco somos um
então você tem que tomar uma atitude
você tem que fazer alguma coisa com essa
compaixão com esses centros justiça que
você faz algo ok você é solidário
aí tem algo
nós descobrimos que unisse 3 dominadores
que a emancipação a emancipação e quando
você é o cara você decide os seus
destinos você traça o seu caminho
estamos falando aqui todo o tempo
autoria da sua própria história
protagonismo da sua própria história e
isso é poderosíssimo porque assim a
narrativa bíblica diz que um dia o cara
deu o livre arbítrio mas eu tenho opções
é preciso ter opções essa e precisa
saber usar essas opções para o seu bem e
para o bem de todos e isso é emancipação
e tem histórias disso foi a menina que
ela é fácil mas quando ela entrou na
faculdade de farmácia da unigran ela
bolsista do projeto resgate e ela
apoiada pelo projeto resgata por exemplo
e ela tá uma situação familiar
complicada e tudo e ela não estava
conseguindo
ela fazia um estágio ea parar de fazer
estágio e parar de fazer faculdade minha
esposa me ligou também são paulo olha
camila vai trancar matrícula boca não
tem condição de continuar os estudos não
têm condição financeira
assim não é de graça não paga pra cima
tem que pagar um tributo não dá
o tamanho de sala de franquia falar com
um executivo de uma multinacional está
errado porque eu tinha quatro estádios
ou moeda remunerados os três não entrei
na sala
o mar está aí o ele perguntou pra mim
se tem uma coisa errada com tinga que
foi está meio chateado
ela também não quer que eu falei a ele
oferece positon br/curriculo deposito
menina contexto da câmera não sei qual o
plano dela tem plano pobre não tem plano
a gente faz até o da palha não tem plano
é que ela precisa para não largar a
faculdade gum antes de palestras e os
personagens de dinheiro e quanto ela
precisa
a lei número que ela ganhava mas o
número que a mãe diarista ela colocava
em cima pode dar de graça porque daí de
graça no brasil caríssimo
então ele foi então tá
então foi o seguinte me põe com uma
mesada para ela eu quero fazer parte
dessa história
em outras palavras o que era ser uma
peça desse quebra cabeça e coloca aí e
ela se graduou 1 ele pagou a inscrição
dela no conselho regional de farmácia e
ela está hoje à frente de uma uma
farmácia garota queria ser fotografada e
nós chamamos nosso querido peninha uma
alma generosa cima que ofereceu se para
estudar de graça
os primeiros passos na fotografia mas
isso não mais que isso
no amor ensino paixão ele se envolveu e
aqui está ele na graduação dela de
bacharelado em fotografia
esse rapaz ele fez um curso de
informática básica
na seqüência ele ele foi fazer um curso
mais avançado paga por uma empresa
daquele idade da cidade e depois ele foi
perfeito na faculdade de sistema de
operação e abrir uma própria empresa
nessa história simples mas não foi
é uma história de superação tremenda mas
ele encontrou que fazia sentido para ele
o empreendedor modelo hoje e lê
ele casou com uma garota que conheceu lá
no projeto resgate também e com isso é
formar uma família e essa guerra também
estava indo na área de uti mas no meio
do caminho ela descobriu que ela não
queria fazer aquilo estava na faculdade
ela mudou de faculdade para fazer
pedagogia e foi se especializar em
crianças com deficiência mental até uma
irmã com síndrome de down ela se
conectou ao seu propósito a essa pedra
do quebra cabeça dela e agora os dois
estão grávidos e ganhar mais uma peça no
quebra cabeça deles
o álvaro passou em engenharia mecânica
um grupo dedicado e tudo também podia
ter tudo para ter bolsa do pronto mas
tinha que ter o dinheiro pra fazer a
matrícula ea primeira mensalidade
ele não tinha grande existe alguém
chegou sério valcanaia foi e cedeu o
dinheiro depois de conseguir de volta
por sérgio
então o que a gente vê um projeto
resgate isso a gente pega é de mistura
oportunidade com apoio e de dedicação a
oportunidade a essas crianças que vêm de
baixo periferia estudou nas melhores
escolas da cidade
as melhores escolas e ensino fundamental
e médio a gente consegue livro a escolas
nas bolsas
a gente vai tarde livro apostila
transporte a editora e amigos aqui que
ela custa de retalho aquele
quebra-cabeça maravilhoso todo ano e
durante o ano não temos atividades em
que eles aprendem estudar aprender a
aprender eles ousam sonhar são
provocados a isso eles elaboram seus
projetos de vida eles perseguem então e
isso amplia seu repertório é uma
experiência muito interessante para eles
e dedicação ele tem que ralar
eles têm que a light tem que correr
atrás e eles fazem isso ele tem que
participar das nossas atividades e
resultar em sucesso
hoje nós temos mais de 185 jovens que
terminaram com os técnicos 450 estão
fazendo terminado a faculdade e tem
engenheiro a farmacêutica temos três
fazendo medicina este ano foram quatro
primeiro lugares dois a federal o
primeiro lugar na geral do estado - da
une sociesc e primeiro grande engenharia
elétrica ou desk 3 fazendo medicina 1 em
buenos aires um aqui em joinville um
novo oscar são pessoas que têm uma
chance real de constituir uma família
que não vai precisar de projeto social e
isso é uma mudança e recentemente
lançamos o think tank
o tema algum filho tem conquistas aqui
você tem os meninos 1º e 2º anos e mesmo
assim começou o 1º e 2º ano ensino médio
eles trabalham em equipe para resolver
um problema de relevância para a
sociedade um problema de pobres nessa
também
a probabilidade é um problema de pobre é
um problema de de educação e existe uma
metodologia loucura com um que é uma
loucura organizando e ele trabalha a
equipe de sete a nove pessoas e eles
aprendizagem 50 foot em teoria umas
viagens legal que tem por aí e eles
desenvolvem assim a habilidade de inovar
de resolver problemas não só isso eles
são orientados por mentores cantores são
pessoas como vocês assim que são jovens
há mais tempo que eles entendem que
entram pra compartilhar com eles a
experiência mais que eles têm ea coisa
legal que esses caras não têm nenhuma
descendência hierárquica sobre os jovens
estão mamando neles não pode tomar a
frente e eles têm a entrega
são 17 semanas têm que entregar o mvp
então é um desafio de liderança tremendo
pra eles que estão na sua primeira
liderança ea coisa bacana que as
empresas reconhecem isso como um valor e
agora somos remunerados para receber os
mentores dos nossos jovens
então está se tornando uma fonte de
receita para o programa de apoio
bolsistas e agora começamos também no
ensino superior tendo a primeira turma
na ufsc que em joinville
alguns aqui presentes e também temos em
florianópolis acontecendo lá na catimba
impactado
então é algo que nós estamos conectando
essas peças
aí tem mais detalhes e mentores mentores
do projecto ter um mentor mastro
são pessoas cujas trajetórias coloca
como referência no mercado na sociedade
e são pessoas que estão aqui
alho são conexões são vivências e querem
enriquecer o seu legado
assim o que nós fazemos é muito simples
somos um mero com sede em miami ser né a
gente as pessoas buscam algo
todos buscamos algo nos conectamos essas
sãs e desejos e procuramos dar um fim
proveitoso ele né
o que faça sentido para cada um e para
todos nós
as pessoas que não se fazem diferença
sim eu sou um meio não me chame de 50% e
por favor por favor nós somos assediados
constantemente no mundo político no
mundo religioso e tudo o divisões fax
semana somos todos gente nós temos os
mesmos desejos por amor por segurança
por felicidade que rever nossos filhos
bem nós temos muito mais em comum é só
encontrar que está disposto a ser tomada
então nosso trabalho é bastante simples
é nós organizamos a energia que quer
juntar a nós capitalizamos os processos
as pessoas se encontram na vida acontece
a gente coloca meninos e meninas da
mesma sala baixa luz foi a música certa
e sai da sala e nada melhor resultado e
sabe como é né
a fidh acontece então assim o nosso
modelo é assim se agrega ok você pobre
uma linha você é rico por ali você preto
marcos e tereza
nós somos assim mas isso não é nossa
natureza
esse não é o nosso projeto nós estamos
aqui para compartilhar algo grandioso
algo que nos faz únicos no mundo como
indivíduos e como espécie
então essa é a nossa contribuição para a
montagem desse quebra-cabeça em que
reunimos sonhos ideais
e paixões de muitas pessoas para fazer o
que todos queremos viver bem obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]